[ELECTRONIC MUSIC]
DEREK SLATER: Hey.
This is Derek Slater.
I'm a policy manager
here at Google.
And welcome back to
another edition of
Google Developers Live.
This time we're talking
about the ITU.
This week, starting in Dubai,
governments from around the
world have gathered to talk
at the International
Telecommunication Union about
the future of the internet.
A number of important issues
are on the table.
And with governments gathering
in Dubai, we wanted to have a
global dialogue of our own here
about this issue with
some of the leaders from around
the world, in civil
society, and internet freedom
groups to speak about this.
You can learn about what
Google's been saying on this
issue at google.com/takeaction.
But today we're going to turn
it over to these range of
leaders from around the world
to hear from them and what
they're doing, what they think,
and what's the next
step in internet freedom around
the world after this
conference.
We'll start with just a range
of introductions So you can
get to know the panel.
Carolina, let's start
with you.
Why don't you introduce
yourself?
CAROLINA BOTERO: Hello.
I am Carolina Botero.
I am a lawyer in Bogota,
Colombia.
And I am directing a
group that's called
Internet Law and Society.
And we have been active for the
last two years, like three
years, on the issues
of digital rights.
And we're very interested
in the ITU.
In fact, we managed to get
ourselves in the delegation to
go and see how Latin American
countries were doing, but at
the end, couldn't travel.
Anyway, we're doing it
from the distance.
And my colleague is Pilar.
PILAR SAENZ: Hello.
I am Pilar Saenz.
I work with Carolina
in the [INAUDIBLE].
And as she say, we are trying
to involve ourselves in the
ITU meeting, but we
can't travel.
But we think that it's an
important, it's a huge meeting.
And we need to rework
[INAUDIBLE] in
a lot of this meeting.
DEREK SLATER: Thanks, guys.
Claudio, why don't you introduce
yourself and your
organization.
CLAUDIO RUIZ: You can
hear me, right?
DEREK SLATER: Yes.
CLAUDIO RUIZ: Well,
I'm Claudio Ruiz.
And I'm director of a Chilean
organization called Derechos
Digitales--
like, digital rights
in Spanish.
And Derechos Digitales is a
nonprofit organization based
in Santiago who fights for human
rights in the digital
environment.
And the kind of thing that we're
working on in the last
year or so was related to
copyright for one side,
privacy for the other,
and freedom of
speech on the internet.
So we're very, very, involved
in all this ITU process and
the way that can in some way be
involved or change the way
of the internet as a platform
for developing human rights.
DEREK SLATER: Marilia,
why don't you
introduce yourself as well?
MARILIA MACIAL: Hi.
My name is maybe
Marilia Macial.
I am a researcher at the Center
for Technology and
Society in FGV in Brazil.
The center is mainly devoted
to research on
intellectual property.
We follow discussions in the
World Intellectual Property
Organization.
And we also develop research
on internet governance.
I've been involved in research
in internet governance for
seven years now, following
different topics basically and
mostly in the UN.
I have been a civil society
representative in the
Commission for Science and
Technology for development,
and on the working group
that has discussed IGF
improvements as well.
And we are following
the ITU debates.
We have a researcher from our
center that has managed to
join the Brazilian delegation.
So we have information that
she's passing to us.
And it's being quite
interesting.
DEREK SLATER: Well we look for
the hearing about that.
Mawaki, please introduce
yourself.
MAWAKI CHANGO: Hello.
I'm Mawaki Chango.
I have worked since the late
19s in the areas of
information and communication
technologies, which we refer
to as ICT in general; policy
and development, systems,
notably at UNESCO, and with the
International Development
Research Center.
And actually during the WSIS
process, I was a Civil
Society-- an African Civil
Society participant.
And later on, just before the
second phase of the summit, I
was a joint United Nations and
a DIPLO foundation fellow at
the Secretariat of the Working
Group on Internet
Governance in Geneva.
Currently actually, I also
served as counselor with
ICANN's generic name supporting
organization for
generic top-level domain
names policies.
And recently I have just
completed, actually, a Ph.D at
Syracuse University.
And my research focus is
identity and authentication,
from digital identity
all the way back to
well medieval seals.
So currently I'm project
coordinator for APC in charge
of internet policy in Africa.
So as to APC, my organization,
which is the Association for
Progressive Communications, it
is a group that works for
[INAUDIBLE] work of
civil society
organizations across the world.
And its focus is particularly
on ICTs and particularly on
internet access across
the globe, and ICT
availability in general.
And as such, APC advocates
for internet [INAUDIBLE]
policy making processes
so that everybody--
what you call nowadays--
[INAUDIBLE]
can have a say in the
policy development
process regarding ICT.
DEREK SLATER: Thanks Mawaki.
Jochai, we'll let you introduce
yourself as well.
Let me start with a
question for you.
And then we can open it up for
discussion across the group.
And it's great to have you all
from around the world.
Jochai, why don't you
introduce yourself.
And then tell us a little bit
about what is going on at the
ITU this week?
Can you give an overview
for the viewers?
Where did this come from?
What's the history of it?
And try and make sense of this
alphabet soup of internet
policy acronyms that we're
talking about today.
JOCHAI BEN-AVIE: Sure.
I'm Jochai Ben-Avie.
I'm the policy director
at Access.
We're an international
organization that defends and
extends the digital
rights of users at
risk around the world.
So we combine a global movement
of users in almost
every country if not every
country in the world, who are
signing petitions, going to
protests, mobilizing around
these issues including
extensively around the WCIT,
which we'll define.
It's the World Conference
on International
Telecommunications.
And then we have a policy shop
that I direct that does
practical policy recommendations
to
governments, corporations, and
civil society, and then a tech
arm that's providing near real
time 24/7 support to activists
on the ground and building new
technologies to support them.
We've been pretty deeply engaged
in the WCIT and ITU
for some time now.
One of our policy analysts
is over there as well.
So let's go through this
alphabet soup.
What is-- the ITU is
the International
Telecommunication Union.
It's a UN agency.
And right now they're
hosting the WCIT.
Basically this is an opaque
government-controlled event.
And the goal is to update a
decades-old international
treaty that's called
the ITRs--
the International
Telecommunication Regulations.
So there are three points to
think about here in terms of
framing the debate and getting
some background here.
Ultimately this is
going to be--
this treaty does need
to be updated.
It is really out of date.
It was last touched in 1988.
And ultimately the biggest thing
that's going on here
is-- or rather in Dubai, I
should say-- is whether this
binding international treaty
and the ITU's corresponding
mandate should be expanded to
internet and internet policy.
This would represent a really
big shift away from the open,
multi-stakeholder institutions
that currently doing internet
policy making.
Another sort of random alphabet
soup-- we have ICANN,
the International Corporation
for Assigned Names Numbers;
the IETF, the Internet
Engineering Task Force; the
EEE, and a variety of others.
And the thing that really
differentiates from the ITU is
that the ITU, only governments
have a vote.
In order to join the ITU--
the Secretary General likes to
make a big point that there
are 700 sector members.
But those 700 sector members
have to pay anywhere between
$2,000 and $35,000
to be there.
And they still can't
speak on the floor.
And this stands in
sharp contrast to
what we're doing here.
In terms of the second point to
know about this process and
what it's been like, the
preparatory process has been
deeply flawed.
Like the ITU, it lacks
transparency.
Throughout the preparatory
process, the only way we've
been able to be able to get
documents has been largely
through leaks.
And it really lacks
inclusivity.
Users have not had a voice.
So society by and large
hasn't had a voice.
And so I think the third thing
to consider is that the ITU
does good work.
It does a lot of really
good work.
We have to remember that this
is not just about the
secretariat.
This is really about member
states using the WCIT to play
up their larger geopolitical
agendas.
And so the authoritarian states
that are trying to
close down the internet to
curtail freedoms online are
pushing proposals
that do that.
You have other blocs of
countries that have really
benefited from the development
work that ITU does.
And so there's less of
a need to expand--
or less concerned with
expanding the ITU's
mandate in this way.
And then I think there's also
sort of a community of folks
who are pushing back against
out-sized US influence in
internet policy making.
I think it's important to
acknowledge this as a really
serious legitimate concern.
And so I think that we
constantly have heard this
along the way, that developing
country voices need to be
heard more and their
agenda advanced.
And so that's why they're
trying to WCIT.
And I guess my questions to--
I'll start with Marilia because
I think she has some
insight into this process,
given her
colleague on the ground.
Do you really feel that the
resilient agenda of the
developing emerging world, the
agenda is actually being
advanced during the WCIT
conversations?
MARILIA MACIAL: Well as a matter
of fact, I'd like to
begin saying that I very much
agree with what you have said.
I think that the ITU has
a very important role.
And the awareness that has
been raised among civil
society about ITU because of
WCIT, I hope it will be
continued after WCIT finishes,
that civil society becomes
more sustainably involved
in ITU's work.
And I say this because I think
it's important to notice is
that on the one hand, we have
this group of states that have
made severely negative proposals
that will impact
negatively on freedom of
information, expression, and
innovation.
But on the other hand, we also
have these group of states
that are trying to make us
believe that UN has no role in
internet governance.
And I don't think this
is accurate.
There is a lot of things that
not only ITU, but other UN
bodies should be dealing with.
Maybe they are not yet taking
these issues into account.
And maybe they're not taking
them as we like them to take
them, in a multi-stakeholder
fashion.
But there are a lot of important
issues that UN
should be dealing with, such
as security and making
security not impact negatively
on freedom of information and
expression, and jurisdiction
issues,
which is very important.
We all know the cases of the
domain name seizure that have
taken place such as Rojadirecta
in Spain.
This is something
very serious.
National jurisdictions, they
impact on other jurisdictions.
And this is something that
we need to look into.
And I think that WICT presents
us with a very good
opportunity not only to know
more about ITU and UN's work,
but also to take a look at
our national regulatory
frameworks.
Probably many people know that
here in Brazil we are in a
very important moment.
We have a regulation that
has been developed in a
collaborative way online.
All the people that use the
internet and been able to make
comments to this regulation.
And after this collaborative
process that lasted for three
months, this regulation has
been sent to Congress.
And now it's being
on the revision.
And because ITU happened at the
same time that this law
arrived in congress, WCIT had
a negative impact on the
discussion of his view bill,
because this bill tries to
enable network neutrality, which
would be fundamental to
the guarantee of innovation
in Brazil.
Because the discussion is taking
place in WCIT right
now, the discussions in Congress
have been stalled,
because our government doesn't
have a position on network
neutrality.
And they wanted to go to WCIT
and hear from other countries,
what are their perspectives,
hear from [INAUDIBLE] what is
their perspective.
So I think that developing
countries that do not have
this regulatory framework in
place as developed countries
already have, this may have
a negative impact.
But it also creates an
opportunity for us to be aware
of how there is an interplay
between international
regulation and national
regulation as well.
DEREK SLATER: Claudio, I want
to turn you on that point,
because is that a comparable
experience to what you've had
with your organization?
Or what are the key differences
with what Marilia
has been discussing.
CLAUDIO RUIZ: I think what
Marilia has pointed out, it's
pretty important.
It's the key discussion in all
this thing, especially because
this [INAUDIBLE]
the WCIT discussion has
been closed doors.
And we don't have a very clear
idea about what the kind of
things that they are discussing,
the documents they
are sharing, and that
kind of stuff.
I will say that although this
discussion has been framed in
some way as a take hands off
the internet from one side,
and from the other side, this
idea of these governments,
this government-centered
agenda trying to
take over the internet.
And I would say it's not
either one idea what is
happening, and neither
is the other.
I would say all the discussion
on WCIT, and all the
discussion about what we're
talking about, it's
just about the power.
And it's just about controlling
things.
And it's more about
a controlling
structure in some way.
So my point here, and experience
that we have here
in Chile, I would say, is just
to try to use this opportunity
and to use this momentum, this
discussion momentum worldwide
international agenda.
And one of the things that at
least here in Chile we have
faced, it's in spite of the fact
that or government has
this digital agenda, digital
plan for the next 10 years,
and we don't have a very clear
idea about and what is the
Chilean position on WCIT, and
why our government is not
opening up the doors to other
civil society organizations or
different multi-stakeholders
and groups to just share
opinions and actually adding
some different points to the
Chilean position.
So I think it's pretty important
what Marilia said
about how this WCIT discussion
worldwide can be useful on the
national level or even in the
regional level, to just
empower different stakeholders,
[INAUDIBLE]
structures to taking
decisions.
And using multi-stakeholders
and groups to discuss the
internet in general, not just
in a technical way, or not
just in a political way, but
taking talking about the
internet as a platform to
developing human rights.
And when we're talking about
human rights, we need to
address all the perspectives
which are involved in those
things, and not just the
government's point of view, or
not just the company's agenda.
So I think that these things, it
would be very interesting.
And I'm pretty concerned about
the way the discussion would
be framed in the future,
taking into account the
importance of the discussion
and taking especially into
account all the media attendance
that is now into
Dubai, and especially in
these human rights
groups around the world.
I think that it would be
very, very important.
DEREK SLATER: And Mawaki, one
of things that both Marilia
and Claudio spoke to as sort
of, this is an important
moment, not just what happens
at the WCIT today, but as a
moment of growing the community
of people who are
thinking about these issues.
You have a bit of
perspective--
APC has been involved in these
issues for quite some time.
And so what is the
history of this
community discussion like.
And where do you see-- where
do you hope it goes now,
coming out of the ITU and the
discussion we're having today
and this month?
MAWAKI CHANGO: OK, thanks.
The discussion about internet
governance has been around at
least since the '90s, at
the inception of ICANN.
People have been more
or less aware of it.
I have to admit that not many
people were involved in the
process at that time, especially
in the side of
African civil society.
And WSIS was a tremendous
opportunity for engagement
around the world, particularly
in Africa.
People have become aware of
internet governance issues and
challenges more acutely since
WSIS, since the preparatory
process in 2003.
And APC has been, of course,
advocating around those issues
since then.
In general, even before the
particular issue area of
internet governance, APC has
always been advocating for
more affordable access
to ICTs and inclusive
policy-making processes.
So with the WSIS, the
internet Governance
issues came to the fore.
Now as we progress, since 2002,
since the WSIS, the
ranks of civil society folks
involved in Africa have been
growing, the main challenge
always being capacity to
building and funding
to participate in
meetings around the world.
With regard to the WCIT itself,
we have started
preparing ICT civil society
participants around the
continent through a discussion
list and a wiki page in order
for them to become more aware
of the issues at stake, and
try to position their respective
governments in
order to be informed about their
governments' positions
and the preparatory process that
their governments engage
in so that if possible, they
can even be part of the
national delegation.
I'm happy to report that some
of our colleagues managed to
get on board with their
government delegation, like in
Kenya, probably also Uganda.
We have been hearing different
updates, if you
will, from the grounds--
and possibly also
Cote d'Ivoire.
Anyway, as Africa internet
policy progenitor, I'm not
focusing particularly
on [INAUDIBLE]
countries.
And I am in the position of
being kind of an observatory
of how different governments,
different countries in the
continent progressing on the
issue of being more inclusive,
being multi-stakeholder in their
policy making processes.
And there has been some low
progress in that regard.
Now coming back to the WCIT's
agenda itself, I believe as a
couple of my colleagues said,
it's really about power
struggle and about control.
Control can be political.
It can be under the guise of
a [INAUDIBLE] security.
It can be about controlling
people and their freedom of
expression and constraining
those rights.
It can also be about commerce
and financial reasons.
What is happening here is that
at the core of the issues is
the fact that government, since
the last 1988 treaty, we
have seen a lot of things
change in the--
sorry, my--
DEREK SLATER: We lost
the lights there.
Let me just--
there we go, and he's back.
MAWAKI CHANGO: The
light is back.
DEREK SLATER: Mawaki, let me
pause you there, because I
want to ask Carolina
a similar thing.
Because I know, Carolina, you've
been spending a lot of
time this year building up
capacity in your region and
working on new projects to try
and bring more people into the
fold of working on internet
policy and understanding it.
What do you think--
what are the big challenges that
you see sort of ahead in
trying to get people to
understand why things like
these sort of treaty
conferences matter?
And what can people be doing
in their communities?
What do you think is effective
for people to be doing to
trying to raise awareness
about these issues?
CAROLINA BOTERO: Well what I
think that the main problem is
I would like to connect
with what Marilia
was trying to explain.
And it is that in our region,
except for only
Bazil and some other--
I don't know, Mexico, maybe
Chile, Argentina have some
kind of role in these issues.
The rest of us are really
behind [INAUDIBLE].
For instance, we have been
trying to follow up positions
in our countries
on [INAUDIBLE]
And what we found is that the
region is meant to be joined
CITEL position, which is an
Inter-American Organization of
Telecommunications for
the governments.
And the point is, there are
39 statements on this
declaration, and really
each country has done
only some of them.
For instance, Colombia just
joined two of those
propositions of the CITEL.
So really, saying that all the
countries are together in the
region with a position in Dubai
is not really true.
The truth is that they have
discussed it a little bit.
And each country has choosed
what to say.
But when you ask them from other
countries, especially
little countries like ours,
they don't really know.
And they don't explain it.
For instance, we heard from
Ecuador that they had tried to
contact their ministry and tried
to find out what the
position is, how
are they going.
And the response from the
functionaries from the public
servant was always, we're
doing all the CITEL's
recommendations.
And that is really not true.
So even the public servants that
are engaged into these
issues, especially in small
countries, are really little
aware of what's going on.
This was one of the reasons why
we wanted to participate
directly in the delegation in
Dubai, because we found out
that in the region,
only Brazil is
attending as civil society.
The rest of the countries are
not having any representatives
from the civil society, which
also means that you have the
gap of language, because--
[INAUDIBLE]
many countries.
And having the information in
our language helps to breach
the situation.
We really find that there is a
lack of information and a lack
of the sources in
our language.
And Derechos Digitales is
actually doing a good job
translating and putting
some resources on.
But it would be great to have
people Spanish-speaking
reporting from Dubai, telling
us what the different
presentations and delegations
from our countries are saying,
because our human impact,
especially small countries
that have very little
delegations on the other hand,
just one or two, they are
not necessarily--
PILAR SAENZ: Clear on
their position.
CAROLINA BOTERO: --clear
on their position.
And it would be very good to
follow them and give them more
information from civil
society perspective.
This is more or less also what
we found in experience during
the last two years of lobbying
in the congress regarding
precisely norms or [INAUDIBLE]
laws that were put forward
into the congress, especially
to control
content on the internet.
I would say that, of course as
Claudio said, that control and
power on the internet are both
issues to be aware of in
[INAUDIBLE].
I don't know if you would
like to add something.
PILAR SAENZ: Well I think that
the other important thing to
say is that, for example, CITEL
documents are open.
But we didn't know them.
And I think that we need more
people doing monitoring the
other [INAUDIBLE]
in the region.
[INAUDIBLE]
maybe there is more information
for our countries
and [INAUDIBLE]
of these countries.
And when you see
the [INAUDIBLE]
the sites, the website, you
just don't see enough
information in another
language.
They [INAUDIBLE]
for example.
But I think that not all the
information is in other language.
So it's important to try to have
more information in other
languages, for everybody.
CAROLINA BOTERO: Just
to follow up.
JOCHAI BEN-AVIE: Derek,
can I jump in here?
DEREK SLATER: Yeah.
Go ahead, Jochai.
JOCHAI BEN-AVIE: I just
want to comment.
I mean, I think Carolina and
Pilar raise a really important
point about the need for
in-language access to documents.
But I want to comment a little
bit about the notion of, we
don't really know what's
going on here.
I think--
we saw on day one, and it was
only on the first day of the
conference that we find out
whether civil society that was
not on a government delegation
was going to get in at all.
They were-- that vote
did go well.
They did allow society to be
at the conference venue, to
attend the plenary sessions and
the Committee 5 sessions.
That's sort of where the bulk
of the treaty writing is
getting done.
But what we've already seen in
just four days of conference,
and only actually less than
that in terms of real
substantive debate, is that
as massive debates divide.
It's very contentious.
And the chair of the WCIT is
pushing a lot of these issues
into what are called
working groups.
This is not working group like
you and I think, it's a couple
people trying to
hammer it out.
It's still all 193
member states.
But civil society is not allowed
to participate in the
working groups.
Unlike the plenary sessions
and the full committee
sessions, they're not
live streamed.
And so it's really hard to
get information out.
And we can get--
those of us who have colleagues
who are on
government delegations
have some means.
But then we can't share
that information.
So again I think you saw the
move for the ITU and its
member states on the first day,
that to make a decision
behind closed doors, to give
a modicum of transparency.
And this is really concerning
given the really dangerous
proposals that we're seeing.
I think everyone sort
of touched on human
rights in some way.
But right now there's a huge
debate about whether to
include human rights at all in
the treaty, particularly.
And that's really concerning
when that's juxtaposed with
proposals like on spam, which
would say that governments can
block any content that has
no meaningful message.
That's a really dangerously
subjective term in the hands
of a government.
And then when you add that with
the obligation to take
affirmative steps, to
take measures--
appropriate measures is
the language used--
to curtail spam.
If you look at the right to
know that would allow
governments to know how their
traffic is routed.
First of all, that would require
a fundamental overhaul
of the internet's architecture,
trying to shift
it more to how traditional
telecommunications work.
But it would also open the door
to widespread, pervasive
surveillance.
And then you have other
proposals, particularly from
Russia, and I'll stop after
this, just to give you--
I just want to contextualize
this in terms of what the
debates are.
Because human rights is not
the discourse here.
The Russian proposal would allow
censoring content that
threatens national unity
and security and is
of a sensitive nature--
these very ambiguous,
vague terms.
And so we're seeing a really
contentious debate that's
happening, actually,
still largely
outside the public eye.
DEREK SLATER: I want to make
sure that as we come up almost
to the end of our time, that we
take a little bit of time
for questions from people
who are watching.
One question that really
is focused on--
obviously internet freedom and
human rights are critical.
Obviously the internet can
also be used for illegal
activities for some
forms of harm.
If this isn't the right forum,
what are the right ways to be
addressing this, or how do you
see that conversation going
forward, how to re-balance
those things?
JOCHAI BEN-AVIE: Are you looking
for me to answer that
or someone else?
DEREK SLATER: I'll leave
it to the panel.
But if Jochai, you want to
jump in, that' fine.
Or Mawaki, you can as well.
MAWAKI CHANGO: OK.
CAROLINA BOTERO: Sorry.
Before you answer, I would like
to make a point on what
you had just said.
What the question Derek
made to us was how
to get people involved.
And what I was trying to explain
is that in countries
like ours, we are like
step three behind.
In order to explain to people
the importance of the meeting,
you first need information
in their language.
And that was my point.
Of course if you're
[INAUDIBLE]
Jochai said it's really
important.
But then you are like
in a step six plus.
You have all these countries
that are
there, and maybe voting.
And they are step three minus.
They don't even-- and not just
their governments, with I
already said.
The public servants
don't know.
And the civil society
don't even care.
So we have to first make that
as an issue, to be able then
to ask, to be there.
I don't know.
I just wanted to make
that point.
DEREK SLATER: No, it's a
great point, Carolina.
Mawaki, you were going
to jump in as well.
Go ahead.
MAWAKI CHANGO: Yes.
I want to say a couple things
about the question that you
just asked.
We need to come back to the
idea, to the core issue of
this ITU debate--
the first question I believe,
which has been the question of
definition.
And it is about knowing whether
internet-related
issues or governance can
be part of the ITR.
And so the definition debate
has been about--
I think the US--
people are finding out about
that debate in the US.
That has been a long-running
debate, whether internet is
part of basic telecommunications
or it's
what you call here enhanced
service, and whether the
telecom regulatory framework
applied to the internet.
So once you understand that and
you understand that the
telecom regulatory framework
cannot apply to the internet,
because of all the content
issues, for example, that you
mentioned, Jochai.
So then the human right
issue does not
even become a problem.
Because first of all, to
ITU is part of the UN.
And there's a clear universal
human rights regime at the UN
organization level,
across the system.
So those proposals going against
freedom of expression
and all that have to be opposed
up front, on the basis
of the human rights regime
that's accepted and is
supposed to be enforced at
the level of the UN.
So at APC, we don't think we
need to include the human
rights issue within the ITR.
Those are issues to be debated,
but not within the
ITR, because the ITRs must be
about basic telecommunicaion
regulatory framework.
So as to the question, where
or how to approach those
issues related to internet,
we have had the Internet
Governance Forum.
The problem is-- which is
multi-stakeholder, everybody's
welcome, civil societies,
governments, and businesses,
[INAUDIBLE]
everybody.
But the problem is how do
we go from integrating,
collecting, and integrating
people's inputs and views into
something that is actionable.
That's what the IGF--
Internet Governance Forum--
has not been begged
to do so far.
So if we can go back to a
formula like IGF but evolved,
from the simple talk shop
to implementation, to
recommendation, that would
be a good way to grow.
DEREK SLATER: Well
thanks, everyone.
We're just out of time.
I know we haven't been
able to hear from
everyone multiple times.
But it was great to hear from
all of you experts from around
the world on this important
subject.
And Mawaki, as you were saying,
this issue of how do
we protect the free and open
internet, how do we protect
freedom online, certainly
something that's a
conversation that isn't ending
here, isn't even beginning.
It's something that hopefully
will continue to expand, and
expand around the world to be as
inclusive and participatory
as possible.
So we thank all of you for
joining us and for all of you
for watching.
Again, thanks for joining
Google Developers Live.
And we'll see you next time.
MAWAKI CHANGO: Thank you.